a little stack of cooked zucchini I
didn't realize being as a video would
make me angry I've been a vegetarian for
about ten years now I decided to be a
vegetarian in high school I was like
walking in the woods with my friends one
day and we were just like let's not eat
meat and it stuck and then a little did
I know she was eating hamburgers
secretly never anybody talks to me about
being vegetarian I just tell them I
don't eat anything that has a mom people
often are like oh you're vegan so you
must be like really healthy I'm like
unfortunately they're not synonymous cuz
french fries are mostly vegan and you
can survive off only french fries for a
long time let me tell you it's
definitely second nature like I always
look like if they're gelatin is their
chicken stock so I have some horror
stories I feel like throughout my life I
know they've pumped to read these today
cuz I feel like I'm gonna be able to
relate to a majority of them so let's
start
my dad and brother offered to cook the
dinner for my wedding Wow we had a
pretty set menu that he came up with
that had a vegetarian option day of my
dad hands me a plate of rice and was
like oh yeah well that's all I made
vegetarian then my brother grabs a plate
and said he cooked all the rice with
chicken broth after 10 years my dad
still thinks it's a phase
on your wedding why do dads have such a
hard time understanding that this is a
life decision I feel like this is so
common to like people will hand me a
beautiful dish of pasta or rice or a
gumbo or medley and they're like yeah we
cooked in a beef broth oh so like but
that's fine right and it's like no
that's not fine that's a big part of the
reason why a lot of us go vegan or
vegetarian is we don't want the animal
involved in any way our school has
veggie burgers but they just added
lettuce and tomato to a regular
hamburger it's just a regular hamburger
that's not much perfect that's not a
veggie burger
they tried I think I remember I went to
like a fast food place and asked for
had like anything vegetarian and they
just handed me like cheese on bread
which was fine it was my 10th birthday
party and we were at an amusement park
to celebrate my parents had already told
them that I was vegetarian and couldn't
have meat and they said they had
vegetarian option
come lunchtime they brought me a hotdog
bun with nothing on it except ketchup
at my own birthday party that's I'm just
wondering if like the amusement park had
planned oh this is a vegetarian option
it's like a bun with tomato or if they
like forgot I was invited to a military
ball and I was told that there would be
a vegan option
turns out the vegan option was for
cheese mac and cheese I ended up eating
tic tacs super relatable so often people
are like so fish I'm like it has a face
I can't eat it Dairy doesn't have a face
but it used to like oftentimes the
vegetarian or vegan option ends up being
like sugary or worse for you and like
generally trying to be like a little
more healthy and then you end up eating
tic-tac I hope they were orange and not
like a mint one I ordered veggie lasagna
at a restaurant freaking alone vegetable
lasagna
I knew the meat lasagna had noodles and
layers yeah so I was expecting the same
thing just with vegetables and without
meat nope I got a literal stack of
cooked zucchini no noodles Oh in there I
feel your pain it's bull that it's not a
lasagna lasagna has noodles noodles I
mean I hope the zucchini was cooked and
not soggy because that's a common issue
for vegetarians you get the soggy and
sweat to the wolves
I went to lunch at a restaurant and
ordered the vegetarian soup when it was
served I noticed something that looked a
lot like meat floating around and it
turned out to be pieces of chicken I
brought this up to the waiter who told
me chicken isn't really meat because
it's a bird
oh I think you think he's not
information
I had no idea so
is not that surprising to me you can
never really trust it no one really
knows what's in it it's been reheated
for days I just went to a banquet and
the only vegetarian options included
mushrooms which I also can't be ended up
eating cake for dinner so not all bad
that's relatable you just go there's
nothing for me to eat so I guess I just
have to choose the dessert for me it's
really hard to be vegetarian or vegan
with like other dietary restrictions
like if you're free I mean at least you
had cake which is cool and I'm eating a
lot of sweets if that's the only thing
that doesn't contain meat
[Music]
I feel like what was cool about these
stories is that they were all so
different and all so many different
circumstances but they're all so
relatable I feel like I've been in every
single one of these a lot of people who
do eat meat don't think about like these
different products that they just
automatically incorporate into something
and like I know a lot of people like to
laugh like oh you're being difficult but
like for some people this is how they
eat just like if you're a carnivore and
you need me every day you got that for
yourself I grew up eating meats I love
cheeseburgers even today I didn't give
up meat and dairy because I don't like
the taste of it in and out I miss you
every day but you know you just
eventually make a decision that you
don't want to be part of an industry
that seems to be doing so many bad
things in my past I've had partners who
like weren't supportive of me being a
vegetarian and so sometimes when we
would go out to dinner I would order
like a salad and a side and we would get
in arguments because they'd feel like
you're not eating enough you can't be a
vegetarian which was very bizarre
it's sad how seemingly little so many
people know about being vegan and
vegetarian but I also know that it's a
privilege in a lot of ways to be able to
eat vegan or vegetarian because it's
more expensive and if you live in a food
desert or you don't have a ton of extra
income it's harder to make that decision
be thoughtful all around for people it's
not hurting you people like to poke fun
at us but we're all about like not
hurting you not hurting me everyone can
do their own thing even though I think
everyone should be a vegetarian
eventually we'd have to phase out
[Music]